it's Christmas time and we are
introduced to a young woman Stacy a
taxidermist who is dancing and waiting
for her food to heat up while watching
TV she switches channels between
cosmetic advertisements and Food review
shows suddenly as she is enjoying a
lovely steak and chicken for dinner she
hears a noise from the basement and goes
to investigate thinking it might be
someone intruding she carries an ax for
her safety and climbs down the stairs
being a taxidermist she has lots of
taxidermied animals in her basement
after searching around the house and
failing to find anyone she calls her
husband a mustachioed cop Keith for help
however he doesn't take it seriously as
Stacy always hears noises that don't
exist Keith believes that she often
imagines things as she wants an intruder
to barge inside their house and harass
her Stacy has become that desperate for
a good intimate session the next day at
her workplace Stacy overhears her
co-worker Gina gossiping with her
friends she is also applying some kind
of lotion to look pretty this makes
Stacy pretty envious as she desires to
be beautiful like Gina the latter talks
about their manager being a lesbian and
makes fun of her appearance all this
time Stacy feels ignored and is bound to
accept that she does not belong to the
group but later that evening she
receives an unexpected invitation to
Gina's Secret Santa party she cannot
believe that the group of beautiful
girls have finally accepted her later
Stacy goes hunting sheets a duck and
decides to turn it into a present for
Gina through Taxidermy well she's gonna
love that as she is busy preparing the
dock Keith returns home and asks are
about the day Stacy excitedly shares
that she has been invited to a party
hearing this Keith gets confused as he
knows his wife dislikes women like Gina
however Stacy explains that she wants to
explore Gina's House's interior and
wants to feel what living in an
extravagant house feels like next it is
night and it's party time Stacy grabs
the present and heads to Gina's house as
she reaches the entrance she gets
mesmerized by its decoration and Beauty
following this Stacy rings the bell and
nearly gets attacked by Gina's
aggressive dog but soon Gina opens the
door and welcomes her inside the house
one of Gina's friends talks about hiring
an escort to have some fun she explains
that she recently got divorced as her
ex-husband couldn't satisfy her
surprisingly other women cheer her on
and begin making funny comments about
their husband's physical attributes he's
such a small PP loser after a while the
group switches to discussing fillers and
Gina recommends her plastic surgeon for
facelifts something Stacy can't relate
to later Gina mentions the party theme
The Not So secret Santa and his
attributes to gift hampers to everyone
this makes Stacy a bit sad as she had
expected it to be a secret santa theme
meanwhile the girls open their gifts and
find expensive makeup kits including the
lotion that Gina was using in return
Stacy also presents the duck that she
prepared unfortunately this disgusts all
the other girls and they start gossiping
about her to break the awkwardness Gina
asks everyone to try on the lotion and
feel the smoothness all the women agree
including Stacy as she doesn't want to
be left out the next scene shows all the
women excessively using the lotion all
over their bodies it appears that they
have been possessed however when Stacy
uses some of it on her face it turns
completely rad indicating that she has
an allergy feeling frustrated she
borrows an ice pack from Gina and
decides to leave the party When Stacy
reaches home Keith notices her bruised
face and advises her against using such
lotions however she expresses her desire
to feel sexy and attractive and curses
herself for having sensitive skin and
Keith tries to cheer her up with his
mustache but to no avail later that
night Stacy finds herself restless and
unable to sleep she keeps scratching her
skin and wakes up to see its condition
in the mirror as she gazes at her
reflection the lotion tube mysteriously
opens by itself and begins squirting out
the cream afterwards Stacy turns on the
TV and suddenly an ad for the same
lotion pops up it encourages the viewers
to change their lives by using the
lotion to Stacy's surprise and confusion
the TV presenter a muscular man named
Harry starts interacting with her he
urges her to apply the lotion on her
face right now Stacy mentions having
allergic skin but Harry replies that
every change requires some pain and
determination he then convinces Stacy to
call the given number and order more
lotion the following day before Keith
wakes up Stacy receives the delivery
from the lotion company and hides it in
the basement later her husband notices
that her appearance has worsened and
tries to reason with her suggesting she
stop using the lotion however Stacey is
so brainwashed by Harry that she
dismisses his concern being fixated on
the idea of the lotion transforming her
beauty after this she continues her
lotion routine watching its
advertisements day and night however
this obsession takes a toll on her and
she begins to scratch her body
uncontrollably even in her sleep Keith
remains worried and advises her to stop
emphasizing the harmful effects his
mustache is worried too one night when
Stacy scratches a lot Heath suggests she
put on oven mats the latter agrees to do
it but when she goes to the kitchen to
get the mitts an unexpected thing
happens the TV turns on by itself and
Harry appears he begins talking to Stacy
and mocks her lack of trust Harry says
that she is a coward who isn't willing
to try new things after this he suddenly
vanishes leaving her unsettled Stacy
begs him to return and surprisingly
Harry appears once again flaunting his
shiny muscles he tells her that the pain
she is feeling is much less than being
ignored and ostracized by the group
eventually Harry tantalizes her with the
idea of a new version of herself if she
uses more lotion driven by the illusion
of a better self developing inside her
Stacy rushes to the basement to follow
Harry's instructions to her surprise she
encounters a mess as all the lotion
tubes in the Box opened up by themselves
and leak in front of her creating a
chaotic scene panicking she hurries back
to her room seeking comfort and safety
in her husband's arms Stacy also pleads
with Keith to stay home the next day to
support her but he sadly admits that he
cannot meanwhile the lotion continues to
flow out of the box and forms a lump of
smelly goo creating an ominous
atmosphere in the room the next day when
Stacy looks at herself in the mirror she
notices something strange happening to
her skin it starts shedding like the
scales of a mermaid despite the
horrifying sight Stacy feels a sense of
excitement convinced that this
transformation will make her truly
beautiful and desirable later when Keith
returns home he lovingly offers her
something to eat but Stacy is too
engrossed in peeling off her skin
instead of responding oblivious to the
disturbing changes in her appearance she
seems fixated on her new quest for
beauty and being accepted into the group
after a while she comes downstairs but
requests Keith not scold or criticize
her eventually the husband agrees and
Stacy joins him but when Keith sees her
infected body he becomes deeply
concerned and urges her to see a doctor
immediately worried about her well-being
he tries to reason with her expressing
genuine care and love however Stacy
interprets his concern as a lack of
support and becomes defensive rejecting
the idea that she might be having an
allergic reaction to calm her down Keith
offers her food and tells her that she
is beautiful from the inside and he
loves her a lot however these words hurt
Stacey and with the desire to transform
her outer self she storms off to the
basement to get more lotion there she is
met with a shocking sight a mysterious
figure is taken form from the lotion in
the Box When Stacy walks closer the
figure mirrors her every movement in a
creepy and unsettling manner Stacy is
both a amazed and disturbed by The
Surreal encounter the bizarre
interaction escalates further as the two
bodies hold hands share a kiss and even
Embrace each other implying a merging of
identities with this Stacy's
transformation seems to be reaching a
critical point and she feels almost
obsessed with the idea of becoming
someone else entirely in her altered
state of mind Stacy grabs a knife and
approaches Keith who is now more alarmed
than ever seeing her soaked in lotion
despite his desperate attempts to remind
her of her true self Stacy remains
convinced that her transformation is
near completion in a terrifying turn of
events when Keith urges her to stop
using the lotion she stabs him in the
forehead with blood oozing from his
forehead Keith becomes delusional in
panics he tries to make an emergency
call using his radio and asks Stacy to
bring a towel however the latter's
actions become even more Sinister
instead of bringing a towel she attacks
her own husband from behind with her ax
multiple times coldly and brutally
ending his life now fully consumed by
her Madness Stacy is drawn back to the
lotion figure which has now filled her
bathtub with the mysterious lotion for
her following the signal Stacy removes
her clothes and dips her naked body into
the tub feeling a strange pleasure
tingling through her in this chilling
and dark moment it becomes evident that
Stacy is descended into a realm of
insanity where her obsessions and
desires have taken control of her
entirely after submerging herself in the
slimy lotion-filled bathtub Stacy
emerges from the bathroom her face now
free from rashes she stands before the
mirror in her bedroom astonished by the
beautiful reflection she sees she then
peels off the lotion revealing beautiful
and glowing skin excited about her
transformation she runs downstairs to
show Keith but shows No Remorse when she
realizes she has killed him instead she
disposes of his body in the basement and
begins to perform Taxidermy on him
afterward Stacy decides to change her
appearance further cutting her own hair
applying makeup differently and adopting
a whole new wardrobe style this dress
transformation Alters not only her looks
but also her attitude leaving her
satisfied with her new self the
following morning Stacy heads to work
after saying goodbye to her taxidermied
husband kept on the couch at the
workplace her presence causes a stir as
all heads turn to order when she enters
the bank even her co-workers who had
previously ignored her are now
fascinated by her appearance they shower
her with praise marveling at her amazing
skin in the last scene during a gossip
session Stacy engages in mean-spirited
discussions about their colleagues and
their husband's appearances she says
that her husband got a stiffy and
couldn't stop the group of women decides
to hang out for dinner and drinks and
they become increasingly touchy and
affectionate with Stacy admiring her new
looks the story ends with Stacy
mysteriously Rising into the air and her
laughter conveying a mix of emotions
confusion accomplishment happiness
fulfillment and anxiety subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank thank you for
watching